you were uh I feel like sometimes people
don't realize like that you did come
from the battle scene that you were like
I feel like we think of your bars as
like you know very funny but I feel like
in that it's your your skills as an MCO
probably aren't respected as as they
probably should be do you feel like this
project you kind of yeah definitely
definitely definitely yeah because uh
you know when I was in D12
I had like a a role to play a character
you know what I'm saying and and
Marshall he really liked it to D voice
yeah so like sometimes the voice what
would have me to he would be worried
more about the you know I'm saying the
funny [ __ ] thing really the line or a
syllable or some [ __ ] like that so
yeah so would you say you were kind of
like hey look your role is to do this
exactly you are the fun you're the
comedic relief of the crew you're gonna
say the most wildest most outlandish
[ __ ] and it's gonna be okay because your
name is bizarre I've been saying wow I
landed [ __ ] but like but in the most
simple way yeah in the most simple way
yeah right put it that way so this this
album his Beats inspired me until it all
his [ __ ] is like straight gutter boom
bap [ __ ] so he was back on your yeah I
was back on my [ __ ] yeah 100 yeah no
girlfriend drama free
CMOS boxing
[ __ ] young hoes
nice CMOS yeah
the raw seed I just do the pills that
that you could get no I do a minus mix
with uh
damn I forgot
no no not Elderberry something else
have you noticed uh it's like a sugar
taste is it like oh it's like the jelly
in the jar silly sat with something yeah
yeah it's like a yeah I know what
channel you have to like eat it dude
yeah I had to I just I can't eat that
[ __ ] so I do black seed oil I just do
the pill
it's it's probably not as as beneficial
but it's yeah it is
getting energy yeah that's all I need
I'm like let me pop one of these boys a
day you know what I mean do you feel
like it you notice like your Health's
getting better like oh you started
[ __ ] with CMOS oh yeah yeah shout out
to Dr sebi man yeah we give you way more
energy you know I used to be narcolepsy
just falling asleep every [ __ ]
weird yeah yeah I don't do that [ __ ] no
more yeah would you say like uh you're
the healthiest you've been uh right now
yeah yeah because you look healthy you
look like you've lost way I had a I had
a um I had a minor stroke too and
seriously and I had to I had to get on
my get on my [ __ ] yeah I had stopped
taking my medicine for like two months
was the reason you had a stroke due to
like lifestyle [ __ ] or was it just some
like you you I had I had became a vegan
and uh basically you stopped taking my
medicine and tried to do it natural and
that probably wouldn't that wasn't a
good idea without concern with the
doctor I feel like people go vegan
but they don't understand it there's
like doubts I didn't understand it I was
doing it because
I was dating a girl that was doing it
I'm a [ __ ] follower
she no but yeah she was getting healthy
from it you know what I'm saying so I
try to do it but I didn't know why I was
doing it right you're just doing it to
do it yeah so I started getting on the
road doing them shows and then at night
time it's three four o'clock in the
morning you high you got the munchies so
all I know is if I go to Just when I go
to McDonald's all I know is I can't eat
no Burger but I could eat all the fries
hell yeah fries hash browns chips rice
Donuts all carbs all carbs so my friend
over there is switching the cameras as a
vegetarian but he's full of [ __ ] because
all he does is eat potato chips french
fries and like literally what you're
saying is all he eats he just eats bean
and cheese burritos okay nachos okay
[ __ ]
bags of Doritos the purple ones right
any type of chips he's tried so if you
ever need a good snack he'll be like yo
yo you're gonna try these chips those
are gas but he eats like an absolute
dumpster fire but you know he's
vegetarian so when he says it to girls
it sounds better the problem is he's
still not getting no [ __ ] so oh yeah
yeah so I think Cyrus should go full
meat again do we think we should get him
back to full meat yeah I've been trying
to convince him
I I can't because become a mediterion
meditarian bro
he'll [ __ ] up a whole baby embryo from a
chicken so he doesn't [ __ ] just
ordering cheese pizzas and [ __ ] yes and
knowing anybody gonna ask him for
nothing and then he'll go to he'll go to
Subway and get a foot long sandwich with
just the veggies on it oh wow I'm like
you're a sick man
wow my thing is if you could eat the
aborted baby chicken what you could eat
the chicken meat
what's up with an egg is it's a chicken
embryo yo [ __ ] up some chicken babies oh
yeah but he won't [ __ ] up the chicken
meat
yeah that's a good ass damn aborted baby
chickens
I never think where's their rights Peta
oh I guess that they're priority for
they are fighting for them I'm sure they
just they're probably throwing Blood on
the floor of like a Chick-fil-A right
now somewhere Kim I know you was this
sick man I'm sick [ __ ] man
we're gonna have a good [ __ ] time man
we're gonna have a great [ __ ] you
just became this sick guy all of a
sudden
now all of a sudden
it's been a long time man it's been a
long [ __ ] time bro